유명인들이 모여 있는 곳인 한남동
유엔 빌리지입니다
안녕하세요 bsn 팬트 팀 김윤은
있니다 오늘은 뒤에 보시는 것처럼
유엔빌리지 중에서도 최고급 주택들이
한강변에 바로 맞닿 있는 곳에 와
있는데요 최상의 파노라마 한강뷰를
조망할 수 있는 고급 주택 단지들을
둘러보겠습니다 이엔 빌리지에 관심
많으시죠네 그럼요 특히나 오늘 저희가
둘러볼이 한강변 라인에 관심이
많은데요 유빌리지 내에서도 비교적 싼
곳과 비싼 곳이 있고 시세가 다양한데
최근 2 3년간이 라인에 100억
대를 호가하는 초호와 주택들이 굉장히
많이
들어졌지만
기타 유명 연예인 분들께서 많이
찾아주고 계신 라인인데요 오늘 저희이
소개드릴 곳이 많아서 빨리 이동해
볼까요네
이동하시고 여기가 올해 가장 비싸게
거래된 아파트 1위 파르크 한남인데
이게 얼마에 거래됐는데 우리나라
최고가 아파트 1위인가요네 파르칸
남은 2020년도에 지어진 이후에
대한민국에서 가장 비싼 가격에 팔린
아파트로도 알려졌는데요 지난해 8월
저녁 면장 약 81평 폭증 매물이
무려 180억
계약됐다 있 지난해 4월 135억
다도 45억 원 어른 금액입니다 와
180억 요즘 경기가 정말 안 좋은데
이런 초국가 주택에서는 금리나 대출
규제에 거의 영향을 받지 않는 자산가
분들이 많이 거래를 하시는 거 같아요
그래서 사실 이런 고급주택 에서는
평당 금액이 어 큰 의미가 없는 거
같기도 해요네 고급 스택 매수자들은
거의 금리나 대출 기재에 영향을 받지
않는 분들이라서 대출 없이 현금으로
매수하는 경우가 많습니다 파르한
남에도 총 17세대만이 거주하고
계신데요 애초에 공급량도 적어서
희소성도 있고 하이엔드 급이기 때문에
미래 가치가 계속 오를 것으로 보고
매수하시면 경우가 많습니다 어 여기는
단지가 이름이 다 같네요네 지금
보시는 단지는 완벽하고 연구적인
한강뷰를 자랑하는 준비라 인데요 1차
3차 4차가 나란히 한강변 따라
위치해 있습니다 근데 단지들이 연식은
조금 돼 보여요네 모두 2000년도에
2001년도에 지어진 단지들이
오래되긴 했지만 오히려 내부 구조는
넓습니다 몇 세대 없는 단지이기
때문에 프라이빗하게 거주하실
외국인이나 대사관 직원분들에게 렌트로
인기가 있습니다 준비라는 그럼 1차
3차 4차는 있나요 2차는 어디
있나요 빌리지의 한강변에는 말씀하신
1차 3차 4차가 있고 비 라 2차만
별도로 국회의장 공간 쪽에 프라이비트
하게 위치해 있습니다 최근에는 매물이
없어 들어가기도 힘든 준빌라 2차
매물 소유주 분도 뵙고 왔는데요
인근으로 보안도 철저하고 단독 정원도
넓게 사용하실 수 있어서 조용한
분위기가 정말 좋더라고요 준비라
이차는 다음에 영상으로 별도로 보여
드리겠습니다 여기는 라우부 한남
앞인데요 뷰가 보시다시피 너무 좋아요
제가 초반에 말씀드렸던 최근 2
3년간이 한강변 라인에 신축된
100억 대주택 중 하나인데요 22년
5월에 입주를 시작한 따끈따끈한
신축이고 지하 2층부터 지상 4층까지
구조에 단 세대만이 거주하는 고급
주택입니다 유엔빌리지 내에서도
하이엔드급 빌라로 손꼽히는 곳인데요
최근에는 엑소멤버 백현 씨가
팬트하우스에 입주하며 화제가 되기도
했습니다 비슷하게 바로 옆에 빌라드
그리움도 20년도에 신축이 돼서 지하
2층부터 지상 3층 규모에 단
세대만이 거주하는 고급주 입니다 전
세대가 한강 뷰에 약 3M 높은
증거로 탁트인 개방감까지 느낄 수
있는 주택입니다 맞습니다 실사용
면적이 약 100평에 달하는 넓은
세대도 구성되어 있어서 입주자의
라이프스타일에 맞춰 공간을 다양하게
조성할 수 있습니다 현재 보시는
수빌라 재건축이 예상되는 부지인
데다가 마지막 남은 연구 한강뷰
라인이라 투자목적으로 눈여겨 보실
만한 단지입니다 강변북로를 따라 차로
이동하시고 눈에 띄는 디자인의
외관으로 많이들 궁금해 하시는데요
상월 때는 국내 대표 건축가 승상
님의 작품으로 달을 감상하는 집을
의미하기도 합니다 그분 퀴즈에서도
한번 봤었는데 본인의 철학이 확고하신
분이더라고요 밤이 되면 한강에 비친
날을 상월 때에서 감상할 수 있다고
해서 붙여진 이름인데 최근에 거래된
매물이 있던데 얼마에 거래가 됐었죠네
올해 상월 때가 40억에 거래된 적이
있고 현재 40억 중반대의 매물들이
있습니다 여기는 기사로도 많이
언급되고 연예인분들도 많이 사시는
아닌가요네 헤렌하우스는 유엔 빌리지
중에서도 안쪽에 위치해 있고 다른
고급 빌라와 차별화되는 독특한
익스테리어로 눈에 띄는데요 전통적이고
클래식한 양식의 외관과 고급 대리석
섬세한 디자인 등으로 인기가 많은
고급 하우스입니다 여기가 요즘 연일
기사에 났던 블랙핑크 제니씨가 50억
원 현금을 주고 매입을 해서 굉장히
화제가 됐었죠 맞습니다 최근에라
테라스를 제니씨가 전입 신고를 맞춰
화제가 된 곳인데요 2021년 2월에
계약을 체결한 뒤 약 2년 반 후인
최근에 잔금 납부까지 완료했습니다
잔금을 2년 반만에 치른 건 조금
특이한 케이스인 거 같아요 그리고
여기가 또 샤이니 키씨가 거주 중인데
나온 산에서 방이 몇 개냐고 질문을
했더니 잘 모르겠다고 대답을 해서
화제가 된 곳이기도 하죠 라테라스
소개 좀 해주시죠네 라테라스 단 15
가구만이 프라이트 하게 거주하는데
전세대 테라스 및 가든을 갖추고
있어서 테라스라는 이름이 붙여졌다고
합니다네 저희가 영상보니까 됐는데요
지금 뒤에 보시다시피 한강주가 너무
멋진데 여기 지금 어딘가요 오늘
소개해드릴 마지막 단지인데요 휠타
트레저 정원에 저희가 올라와 있어요
저희가 아직 보여 드리지 못한 유엔
빌리지 단지들이 너무 많아 가지고요
다음 편에 다시 한번 돌아오도록
하겠습니다 지금까지 영상 시청해
주셔서 정말 감사드리고요 다음
영상으로 찾아뵙겠습니다 감사합니다
감사합니다